[Music]
we did some research to find out the
income sources of different celebrities
we're going to share them with you right
now and a piece we're calling yes it's
also called George Washington was a
shallow [ __ ] who went clubbing you
picture pop up Axl Rose 30% touring 20
feet residual it's 50% modeling for look
like you're taking the mean dump Magnum
Ted Cruz 40% campaign donations 25%
appearance fees 35% eating Billy Goats
that cross his bridge then stealing
their wallets Billy Goats 40% selling
homemade jeans percent money found while
eating 30% performing on pornographic
website for Saders Wow
oh my god here we go yes aiders 60%
circus freak shows 20% posing for
illustrated fantasy novels 20% selling
Ted Cruz fresh delicious Billy Goats oh
my god there's three of them that hook
together I love it when a joke that has
a 40% chance of making it on its
tethered you're like you kind of have to
do we're doing it I'm doing it remember
buddy we're counting on you it says
fourth joke yeah hang on pal without you
I'm dead yeah we need you I've got kids
to feed they'll be part of this bit oh
I'm a seder joke I got nowhere else this
is the only joke on Tico I'm a seder
joke that hooks back to Ted Cruz and
Billy Goats so if I know you know Ted
Cruz eat goats that old Rip around
[Music]
you